we got a question here from X Andra has
a question for us maybe buying nice
things is less about impressing someone
else and more about looking for approval
from someone anyone could showing off
luxury goods actually be a form of
people pleasing absolutely I think we're
trying to appease people we're trying to
please them so they feel good about us
but that is not the path to abiding
acceptance you know someone you might
pull up in a Ferrari and it looks really
cool and people like you for that moment
but they figure out you're just a jerk
and you're using them and yeah they're
pleased for the moment but they're going
to be displeased as soon as they learn
about who you are as a
person absolutely um who doesn't want to
feel special who doesn't want to feel
cool we all do right it's baked into
Humanity I I don't know this person
personally I only read this you know
kind of on Twitter but um I applaud him
for sharing his thoughts on it the the
founder uh or creator of Minecraft M uh
kind of went on the record about his La
experience um you know he obviously did
very well Minecraft sold for a bunch of
money and he bought a really fantastic
home here in La 80 million or something
like that and and he
he he shared his perspective on Twitter
and he was like yeah I bought this home
single guy or what have you and he was
throwing parties and of course I'm
paraphrasing
um but he's like I've got all the top
DJs and house full of people that I
don't know and he was sad about it you
know what I mean he had kind of done the
entire thing to make himself feel cool
all the trappings everything you're
supposed to do right the big DJ the
pretty girl in the $80 million house in
the
cars and he talked about uh how hollow
an experience it was for him and uh and
I found that that uh very very
fascinating again I don't know him
personally so I have no further Insight
other than that but it was a it was a
cautionary
tale it seems to me what you're
Illuminating these people start to
figure out that a simpler life is a
richer life in some ways right and
simpler relative to overabundance now we
get to figure out what overabundance is
like what is essential to me is probably
going to be different from what's
essential for you and certainly what
adds value to my life is going to be
different because that's so highly
perspectival and yet at the same time
it's much more about more not
simplifying our lives but lecting Our
Lives adding complexity to our lives in
a way that in the moment feels like it's
what you're supposed to do to interweave
more and more complexity into our lives
and then we get to a point often it
takes some sort of tragic event like for
me as my mom died my marriage ended both
in the same month and you look around
you're like oh I've complected my life
in away I've interwoven all of these
things in that I need to untangle it's
become so tangled that I'm miserable and
now is the time to simplify I went
through that experience myself tell me
about like um you know look
I I wouldn't be sitting here on this
podcast two years ago right like I was
the living embodiment of all of these
things that we're
discussing uh you know I was a
workaholic uh you know I was you know
leading this crazy life you know like um
and of course it all had to come
crashing down right of course we all
have to come back into into perspective
we hope anyway I guess some people never
get out but um you know like this summer
I I made a number of changes right I I
got a house on my daughter's Street you
know I went through divorce and I've got
an 11-year-old and so I I literally
moved on her Street in Palm Springs and
some things that were just you know I
realized that me personally I was being
a highlight re dad I plan great
vacations and parties for a living and
so I was doing all this fun shiny stuff
with my daughter
but I wasn't a real dad the stuff that
nobody cares about that no one remembers
I wasn't there for and so I set my
schedule to you know make her lunches
and take her to school Monday Tuesday
Wednesday the days no one will ever
remember but us yeah um because the
things that matter and the things that
are important
[Music]
um aren't really the highlight real
stuff and so literally one of the
reasons I think I'm able to help our
clients is because I am very much living
and have gone through this great
personal
transformation uh which is the the
subject of my book tell me about the
book the book you're still working on it
right I'm I'm near the end it uh it
essentially tells the story of um of a
couple of years in my life where the
worst things that I could ever imagine
happening to me all kind of happened at
the same time it was very necessary mind
you uh because you know I asked a
question
earlier how do you ask for help if you
don't know you have a problem
I was going through life successful
right building companies making it doing
it but I was uh I was not a conscious
person uh you know I was born July 27th
1973 in Memphis Martin Luther King was
assassinated in Memphis 5 years before I
was born my mother drank from Black's
only water fountains in high school it's
a c it's a very different time and place
completely different world and and um I
grew up in a poor but loving family I
tell people that I didn't even know we
were poor until I became an adult and
went back and was like oh wow we were
really poor CU my my grandmother this
amazing caregiver um you know she never
earned more than $12 any hour but
somehow she made a house of eight people
have everything that they needed and
much of what they wanted it was like
this great great kind of caregiving
thing but a pivotal thing happened to me
in my childhood uh about 9 years old my
mother uh
married um and the adult stepsister of
uh my stepfather I'm 9 years
old trigger warning here I guess um
starts raping me okay
now in
1982 a boy could not be raped by a woman
in America right that's true there was
no such thing right right so you
remember all these School teachers right
they would sleep with these boys and get
you know they would go to prison because
you know if if a boy had text I had a
boy you got lucky right like proud of
you this sort of a thing right so I'm
traumatized but I have no idea that I am
right because again there is no such
thing as mental health there's no such
thing that this is even a crime and I
don't even I don't know what trauma is
or any of this stuff and so literally my
my trauma response was
workaholism now that workaholism made me
very successful okay like I did more
stuff in those you know 9 to 48 when my
when my moment happened those whatever
that is 38 years or whatever in between
I did more stuff you know than than two
or three people who've lived lives and I
I wasn't conscious I was here I was
leading a life I was a dad people talked
to me people knew me people even liked
me but I wasn't in touch with who I was
if that made any sense right and so I'm
building businesses and I've sold
companies and I've done all this great
stuff but I'm not myself and so the book
opens on March 4th
2021 there's a knock at my door it is
Los Angeles County
Sheriff's and the sheriff serves me with
a restraining
order which accuses me of drugging and
raping my ex-girlfriend at
gunpoint and like the needle on a record
getting
smacked that was my
life
instantaneously my whole life you know
literally has changed
she fills out a police
report LAPD is investigating I'm facing
25 years in prison you know what I do
for a living you know who my clients are
I can't speak to my clients I've got
Fortune 100 CEOs who are my clients I
can't like I'm I am done right this is
in the middle of me too like my my life
is over I hire this crazy dream team of
attorneys okay Robert Shapiro who was on
OJ Simpsons dream team was actually my
criminal defense attorney um like a
royal mess as crazy as it could
get in preparing my
defense
um I had to look back at the electronic
record of my
life when the accusation first came I
was actually
like did I do
something here's this person that I've
known half a decade I've been to 30
countries with this person was dear to
me someone accuses you of something that
serious I'm like well I must have done
something because in my childhood I've
always had severe memory problems and
I'm like maybe I blacked out maybe I did
right in her
accusation you know she was like oh he
abused me for five years so this forces
me during Discovery come back to this
point this forces me in Discovery to go
back through my life I have to sit down
and look at every video in my phone I
have to read every text message between
she and I we worked together she was in
the business have to read all the
messages
again when I consumed all that media I
could see that there was no abuse but I
saw something else I saw that I had not
been the father that I should have been
to my own children I could see for the
first time that I wasn't the husband
that I should have been uh to my wife I
could see me
consciously for the first time right and
it was
like I don't want to be that person and
the thought had never crossed my mind my
48 years of life to that moment I had
literally never once thought I'm just
going ahead doing my thing making money
CH now I couldn't stop and do anything
about it because I'm fighting for my
life I'm facing 25 years in prison but I
had seen it the the I wasn't free but I
recognized that I was in jail mental
incarceration right that I so I go back
to fighting and the punch line comes the
punch line is pay me $1 1.1 million it's
a demand letter and we'll make it all go
away
oh right pay me $ 1.1 million in 14 days
it will make it all go away so I give
all of the evidence to my
attorneys thinking they're going to see
this evidence they're going to see what
I saw I mean this man freed OJ Simpson
he didn't have any evidence fre OJ if he
sees my evidence 5 years like clearly
there's no evidence of abuse like I'm
thinking he's going to come tell me
everything's okay so we sit down in the
office Robert Shapiro gives it to me
straight I'm I'm ready like I'm GNA be
okay right Shapiro says here's what
you're going to do you're going to pay
her I'm like what pay her did you not
see my he's like you're going to pay
her because he gives me this Zinger he
says if you have a problem that money
can solve
then you don't have a
problem great line I'm like spin cycle
right I'm like he's like
son this is going to ruin your
life the first trial and there were
three you know the restraining order
Heering the criminal investigation and
the um the civil lawsuit if I didn't pay
the 1.1 million it's like three trials
anybody can get a restraining order
anyone right you guys dated for five
years
you never had a never sent a mean text
never had an argument in five years
she's going to get a restraining order
against you and if she gets a domestic
violence restraining order that's going
to make LAPD charge you in the criminal
pay the girl wrap it up be done with it
it's over I leave that day May 18th 2021
Crest Fallen I am I had told everyone in
my life I was going to fight this no way
right and the best attorney money could
buy in the state of California had just
told me no you're not you're paying this
and I went home and I sat at my dining
room
table told my ex-wife told the young
lady I was dating at that
time hey I've got to
settle and I have one problem while I'm
sitting at the
table there was one person that I could
not
tell and that was my 9-year-old
daughter and I sat at that table from
about 10:00 at night until 8 the next
morning and I thought about everything
that it took for me to get there and the
women in my life and the sacrifice
moving North Memphis to the hills of
West
Hollywood and I thought about my my
little
girl and
um what it would mean for me to settle
and leave her to wonder for the rest of
her life was my father one of those men
did my father do that did
he and I had to confront literally I'm
facing 25 years in
prison and I'm
like I need to make this go
away but I can't look my daughter in the
eye and tell her
this and I called Shapiro the next
morning 8: a.m. 9:00 a.m. and I'm like
I'm sorry Bob we're not settling
we're going to court he's like you can't
go to court I'm like we're going
he's like the trial is in 12 days
continue follow continu get your head
together I'm like we're not delaying
this trial we're going to court Santa
Monica Courthouse 12 days later we're
standing there walk in the
door female judge first words out of her
mouth Mr Flemings are you under a
criminal investigation I'm like yes your
honor I am she says the same thing
Shapiro said she's like then you can't
do this restraining order hearing
anybody can get a restraining order this
is the judge right I'm like I'm shaking
in my boots because Shapiro just told me
this like you know like don't do it the
judge is like look I'll make you a
deal I the judge will call this whole
thing
off I will delay the restraining order
hearing for a year you get a free Year
let LAPD investigate because anything
you say here today is going to be used
against you okay so let's not have this
restraining order hearing let LAPD do
their investigation and if we need to
have restraining he we'll come back in a
year and we'll have it how does that
sound I said thank you your honor but no
thank you I need a verdict and I need it
today and the judge looks at me
like has lost his mind he looks she she
she looks at my she looks at my attorney
she doesn't even say anything she just
looks at him like is he is he crazy my
attorney is like yes you're
he knows what he understands fully what
he's saying and the judge is like stars
okay um she says well before you waste
the time at this court go outside and
see if you can
settle so you don't waste time just go
see if you guys can settle this before
we start the trial we go
outside her attorneys basically they're
like pay us $67,500 and we'll make it
all go away right now my attorneys are
like bro that's the deal of the century
you've already spent $300,000 in legal
fees 675 take that deal like where do we
sign they're ready to go like
sign but I was
convicted and I said you're not
listening to what I'm saying I'm not
going to settle a rape allegation for
one penny I will never look my daughter
in the eye and tell her that I settle
rap allegation not happening we're
having a trial my attorneys are like
you'll be sorry we told you
so I'm like I'm going to have to be
sorry so we go in trial starts she's the
plaintiff she goes first female
judge she starts telling her
story 5 hours into it the judge waves
her hands and says I'm ready to rule my
attorney says your honor we didn't
present a case or call a
witness the judge says you don't need
to the judge calls her a liar From the
Bench dismisses her claims with
prejudice ending effectively the
criminal investigation and any the the
dismissal with prejudice meant she
couldn't even file the civil lawsuit
like you can't make this claim in
another Court this man should have never
been here sitting here accused to this
to begin
with and I'm the only man that I know of
in me too for whom the judge ordered his
accuser to pay a portion of his
attorney's
fee wow and that was how I began my
journey back to myself it was it was
bitter medicine
in the moment but it was necessary for
me to sit here and talk to you today as
a conscious human being um connected to
himself and and doing what I'm doing
that's the opening of the
book right I want to acknowledge you for
being so
vulnerable be able to come on to a show
like this and and talk about that and
even as you started talking about I'm
like uh oh even in my mind will our
audience be disappointed you know but
then I'm like no this this is what
humanity is about we're all going to
face something we're all going
to run into people who lie to us or lie
about us or back to the wedding question
try to con us in a way that they feel is
not immoral and I bet if you get into
that woman's head she has a story about
why she's
right so this is a funny postcript
again this is a person who was dear to
me she knew my children she knew my
family we built a a business together
okay um obviously I was very upset after
the trial I sued her afterwards in
separate like a Civil Trial because we
worked together and she had equity in my
company like I I filed a
lawsuit and after at the the second
trial the judge again judge judges if
you ever go to court they like to tell
you in these civil matters or whatever
you know between two parties they like
go outside and see if you could settle
rather than wasting my time right there
that's a thing that they all do
apparently I didn't know that so the
judge made us go and talk to each other
so the the the criminal thing already
done right just like no more I suit her
judge like y'all go
talk we wound up having a two-hour
conversation outside LA County Court
that's my first time seeing her since
the accusation and of course there was
only one question to talk
about
why and after some weird back and forth
she actually told
me she
said I thought you would
pay I never thought it would go that
far I thought you
pay and I was
like but you know me you know that's not
who I am you could have asked me for
help you could have asked me for the
money absolutely like we work together
what have you but you know me as a
person like you know I could never do
that wow just like I thought you'd
pay I can't embellish that any further I
mean that's the that was
it and uh she actually signed the
settlement agreement from my lawsuit
return the equity and my company free of
charge
and but uh yeah have you been able to
let no absolutely absolutely in fact
that was actually what prompted me
telling you that like if why if was ever
able to ask her why what happened here
what's what's going on I actually think
her true answer would be she doesn't
even know why she did
it I think the Universe I I needed this
to
happen and I mean think about the
symmetry of
being raped as a 9-year-old boy
triggering my problem and the accusation
of a rape 38 years later bringing me
back right and all of my personal
insanity and excess and every crazy
thing that I did in
between I needed it to happen I actually
think she was a change agent in my life
and some crazy way all of the things
that I had done led up to her accusing
me and it was necessary to happen to me
in that moment
uh told you earlier that the worst
things that could ever happen to me I
thought they didn't happen to me they
were happening for me they were creating
something they were bringing me out
of literally lack of Consciousness and
um and that was the beginning the the
ending is even wilder than the than the
beginning but that's the beginning oh
ladies and gentlemen Ray
fliming I hope you enjoy that highlight
if you'd like to see another one check
out this video video right here if you
like to see that full episode check out
this video here or if You' like to dive
deep into the full private podcast
subscribe via the patreon link in the
description your support on patreon is
what allows us to keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free